so this video has gone viral it's a
video of a Karen can you pick my rug
back up because I saw that you flipped
it over early it was not bothering you
sir I don't think it's appropriate I'll
be home at 5 30. make sure you out make
sure you're there man look I'm not
trying to be ugly and I'm not trying to
cause any scene with you whatsoever we
live in a family environment here I have
children here too to me having the F
word on your doormat is not respectful
of anyone that lives here and it's not
respectful of you to touch my property
first of all this woman has not done or
said anything that deserves to be
labeled Karen I hate that term because
Karen is simply a racist smear against
white women that that is what it is and
so if you're one of these people that
goes around using the term just stop
using it it's originally a slur by black
people on social media to uh smear and
make fun of white women that's where it
comes from and now to the point where
it's just like if you're a white woman
between the ages of 40 and 80. if you
God forbid get upset about something
you're automatically a Karen